la sphère griveaux et dans son sillage
les propos de christophe castaner sur le
patron du premier secrétaire du ps qui
avait dénoncé la veille la légèreté
incroyable de l'ancien candidat à la
mairie de paris
nouvelle salle de réaction de la part de
la classe politique indigne et une
nouvelle fois à la sphère griveaux que
dit elle sur la société française y
aura-t-il un avant et un après comment
surtout l'aperçoit ton à l'étranger
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes sur
ce plateau avec roanne rosé dorado
journaliste espagnole correspondant à
paris bon soir roanne rosé dorado merci
d'être avec nous en direct par skype
matteo gisèle berti rédacteur en chef de
putsch italien on le précise
bonsoir météo gesell berti merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france juan
rosé dorado la première question est
pour vous comment avez vous perçu vous
cette affaire grivot en tant que
espagnol en tant qu'étranger
correspondant à paris
salut vous étonner un petit peu oui
surpris tout à fait parce
qu'effectivement on s'attendait pas à
révélation des ces vidéos des monsieur
veja grimaud est d'autant plus que nous
laisse espagnole s'intéresse beaucoup à
la politique française et notamment à
ces élections municipales et notamment à
paris puisque la maire sortante madame
anne hidalgo et est né en espagne et de
ses relations avec l'express où
d'importantes on connait vraiment des
suiveurs de l'actualité de la politique
municipale à à paris les élections qui
s'annoncent au mois au mois de mars donc
on était vraiment vraiment surpris
encore une fois on s'attendait pas qu'on
personne puisqu'il n'y avait pas eu des
rumeurs souvent les journalistes on a
des rumeurs des commentaires quelques
jours auparavant qui vous disent qu'il y
a quelque chose qui va se passer
c'était pas vraiment le cas pour nous
cette fois ci donc encore une fois la
surprise mais bien sûr on s'est beaucoup
intéressée et on a beaucoup travaillé
sur ce qui s'est passé les premiers
jours avec le renoncement à
à être candidat à la mairie de paris
mais aussi sur les conséquences des ce
renoncement par rapport à mai ce qu'on
vaut mais aussi par rapport à la
république en marche et même à monsieur
mc ren et puis bien sûr aussi on s'est
intéressé aux protagonistes de cette
affaire puisque parmi les protagonistes
de cette affaire
il a un particulièrement qui est né en
espagne d'origine espagnole ce monsieur
juan branco donc il y avait beaucoup des
récents qui faisait que nous les
espagnols les journalistes espagnols
correspondant à paris étions intéressés
ont ce qui s'est passé depuis une petite
semaine est là on va aller plus en
détail un dans la réaction notamment des
espagnols on va se tourner vers météo
jose alberti l'italien s'est pas très
loin de l'espagne vous aussi matteo
surpris par cette affaire griveaux et
cette démission sans doute tout a été
très rapide
je dois dire que j'aurais cru que
l'ancien candidat à la mairie de paris
recule restait encore un petit peu
doit on dire leur dans l'allée mais
effectivement tout était très grave
en italie la chose tirer l'attention de
médias mais ils ont réussi ils ont tout
simplement subi ce qui s'est dit dans
les médias français
ils ont suivi aussi un peu l'évolution
du point de vue juridique et judiciaire
surtout de la question mais vous n'êtes
pas trop étonné parce que toute façon on
n'a pas eu vraiment des mecs des
situations similaires
naissance d'un candidat qui est obligé à
démissionner ou en tout cas s'est retiré
dans une course dans les dernières
journées mais sans doute dans la
politique italienne connaît aussi
d'autres situations
oui effectivement vous évoquez
certainement la situation au silvio
berlusconi évidemment on va en parler
parce que la question évidemment tout le
monde se pose c'est la même chose en
espagne est ce que le même candidat est
ce qu'il démissionne
il reste au pouvoir et les espagnols se
disent bon pas écouté c'est pas grave
c'est sa vie privée et le candidat reste
où justement ça aurait été certainement
la même situation
alors on n'a pas eu la même situation
dont c'est difficile de dire mais par
contre non mais on connaît la mentalité
oui mais bon la vie mais on a eu un cas
assez semblable à c'était en 2012 ou in
conseillère municipale de la ville d'in
ville de près de tolède avait envoyé une
vidéo érotique à un de ses copains
copains qui a publié cette vidéo
la première réaction de cet élu a été de
le dénoncer bien sûr mais aussi des
démissionné en tant qu'élu municipal de
sa ville de sa ville donc la réaction
première était dé démissionner mais à
l'époque je vous le rappelle c'était en
2012 a fait quand même assez assez loin
la loi l'interdît ces panneaux ne
n'interdisait pas la diffusion des
vidéos de cette caractéristique des tout
simplement parce que la loi espagnole à
l'époque considéré que si vous envoyer
une vidéo et cette vidéo et publiée par
la personne qui l'a reçu volontairement
de votre part il n'y avait pas de peine
à appliquer des puits est ce qu'elle est
c'est d'affaires évidemment différent en
france
et puis ce qu'a fait la loi espagnole a
changé est devenu comme la loi française
c'est à dire que maintenant il faut donc
avoir l'autorisation de la personne qui
a envoyé la vidéo pourquoi la premier
donc à votre réponse a priori ça se
serait passé de la même façon parce que
dans d'autres dont d'autres cas où des
élus ont commis peut-être par des fautes
pénales m'aider
et d un père par rapport à cette fois à
son attitude vers la population ou à
certaines axes de sa politique
on se sont vus rapidement vu mettre des
côtés n'est pas une faute
on est dans la morale donc par contre
effectivement du côté espagnol on tient
beaucoup à l'exemplarité entre
guillemets donc si effectivement vous
êtes entre guillemets toujours coupable
de quelque chose de amoral il est
probable que vous soyez obligé de
démissionner tout simplement parce que
vous n'avez pas très loin et puis on
savait de toute façon dans le cas de
monsieur rivaux que malheureusement pour
lui disons que les enquêtes d'opinion ne
lui était pas favorable non plus pour
pouvoir continuer à être candidat parce
que c'est vrai que il ya la décision en
propre et personnels de benjamin
griveaux mais il ya aussi l'opinion
publique qui finalement on a allumé
toutes les chaînes de télé et lui toute
la presse alors ça ne reflète pas
forcément nécessairement toujours
l'opinion des français on la connaît pas
nécessairement sur ce point mais qui a
quand même largement défendu benjamin
griveaux disons que c'était
effectivement là lui la victime c hall
aux yeux de la loi elle est
effectivement vous avez réagi comment
vous en établi par rapport à ça
effectivement disons que c'était plutôt
une inertie comme celle des français
face à cette situation parce que la
victime était effectivement benjamins
quentin sans cette vidéo a été publiée
[Musique]
avec le passage du temps on a vu que si
elle est aussi des situations un peu
plus complexe à définir ce qui est
intéressant c'est en tout cas le fait
que comme
c'est en dorado avec des puits 2012
depuis une dizaine d'années la situation
a changé vraiment un peu dans tous les
pays européens heures ce qui concerne ni
les crimes à questions liées à la
diffusion de vidéos non seulement à
caractère pornographique mais aussi
qu'ils ont comme protagoniste de jeunes
par exemple le à l'école des cas de
cyber-harcèlement la loire ont changé
beaucoup à l'italie il ya eu un cas qui
n'a pas concerné un homme ou une femme
politique mais une fille qui a été
effectivement victime et qui est un peu
le même cas de 2,2
benjamin guégot mais cette chose a
permis de devancer un petit peu surtout
du point de vue technique aussi parce
que c'était pas encore c'est compliqué
pas facile c'est encore compliqué de
enlever des contenus d'internet de
contenu des vidéos de ce type qui porte
atteinte à la dignité d'une personne
nous on a eu du mal à vous avez parlé de
la victime c'est vrai il est la victime
parce que la loi dit qu'il est il est
victime mais l'espagnol a eu du mal
aussi à défendre le fait qu'il soit la
victime dont les sources qu'il n'aurait
pas eu des cadres ivo s'il n'y avait pas
eu des vidéos personnes lui avaient
débordé des registres ce type de vidéos
et de l'envoyer sachant le risque que ça
peut nous poser pour un homme politique
donc un homme public qui ont plus à
l'époque il était ministre il était même
pas candidat les pannes et ministre
c'est encore plus plus plus plus plus
compliqué et puis il faut pas non plus
oublier que la france paraît qu'il
découvre la sphère griveaux mais on
oublie qu'il y a quelques années il ya
eu quelque chose de semblable honfleur
en france c'était le cas valbuena avec
karim benzema une vidéo aussi sexuelle
qui était publié
et qui a eu d'écho même le procès n'a
pas encore vraiment terminée eu lieu en
fait et qui va avoir lieu
donc ce n'est pas la première fois que
ça arrive et l on a été surpris des
devoirs comme en france comprenez ça
comme si c'était la première fois banon
c'est pas la première fois
c'est déjà arrivé et encore une fois ce
qu'on veut en espagne en a cette
sensation se connaître et moralisateur
en france quand on parle vert vers les
publics mais qui ne l'est pas du tout
quand on porte un regard sur sa vie sur
sa vie privée
la vie privée et la vie publique c'est
vrai qu'il ya une ligne qui est des plus
en plus minces mais en même temps
c'était aussi on considère que les
hommes politiques ont aussi quelque
chose à faire là dessus c'est à dire on
ne peut pas aller sur les plateaux de
télé ou de radio pour parler de ses
enfants de sa famille on peut pas aller
sur les couvertures d'aider la presse
people et puis demander qu'on ne
s'intéresse pas à votre vie privée que
vous-même avait étalé donc il ya
quelques années la france fait c'est
très bien la différence
merrick une quinzaine d'années en france
on fait plus vraiment cette différence
et c'est surtout les hommes politiques
qu'il a qui la font pas donc faut faire
très attention et c'est pour ça qu'on a
parfois du mal à considérer que tu es
dans des cas comme ça les personnes ces
personnes dans le cas de benjamin
griveaux sont vraiment les premières
victimes matière chez albert si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord justement c'est
peut-être vous parlez de silvio
berlusconi devait être habitué noah ne
pas s'occuper demeure bien que sans lui
aussi
tout un tas de politiques qui ont étalé
leur vie familiale
l'italie a été longtemps un peu moins
mais elle a été longtemps un pays très
catholique donc les enjeux politiques
ont souvent présenté leur modèle
familial comme un modèle de la famille
parfaite mère des problèmes derrière
mais est en revanche ce qui a changé
beaucoup en italie notamment depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir mais aussi dans le
parlement
quand il s'était la protection du
mouvement 5 étoiles et qui a imposé son
une feuille de route aux institutions
italiennes pour que on observe le
comportement vis-à-vis des institutions
et donc aussi des citoyens très con dire
modèle effectivement souvenez il
l'année passée l'un des secrétaires
d'état qui était un représentant de la
ligue 2 matchs et ça finit bien qu'il
que sa famille était encore il a dû
démissionner pour une faute de la part
de cette personne de ceux responsables
politiques et aux yeux de la loire
benjamin griveaux n'est fautif de rien
on est dans la pure au moral a justement
la chose par contre que qui est très
intéressant dans ce cas c'est que
benjamin griveaux a été jugé par
quelqu'un qui finalement a estimé que
comme il faut pas payer
postés mais alors que effectivement il
avait commis aucun crime
et voilà c'est effectivement rosé dorado
mateo gil abertis qui fait référence
alexis viêt russe piotr pawlenty qui
aujourd'hui se plaignait voilà c'est une
situation monstrueuse parce que je
pensais que la france était le pays de
la liberté d'expression est un peu vexé
qu'on enlève sa vidéo du site et voilà
il revient sur cette rhétorique benjamin
gayraud qui a utilisé sa famille en se
présentant comme une icône
quelle a été la réaction des espagnols
par rapport justement à cet argument qu
avance cet activiste russe opposant
d'ailleurs à poutine déjà la première
des choses c'est que ce qu'on a bien
compris si vous voulez c'est que
l'argument will nous il a dit c'est pour
dénoncer l' hypocrisie ça on l'a tous
bien compris effectivement il ya une
certaine façon bien et qu il ya une
forme d' hypocrisie puisque la vie
politique qui ça sort l'espagne que ce
soit en france que ce soit en italie mon
collègue sait bien comment ça se passe
en italie
les politiques sont tombés dans les
progrès si depuis des décennies 2
d'années est donc cet argument là on
peut bien le comprendre le comprendre
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a du mal à
trouver et monsieur vive la démocratie
tout de même si on commence à balancer
en pâture la vie privée des gens c'est
déjà vrai sujet non c'est un vrai sujet
mais déjà il ya la loi
quand je vous ai dit que l'espagne a dû
changer la loi parce qu'à l'époque en
2012 elle permet tait ce type d'aidé
chausseur et l'artiste russe n'aurait
jamais été et molestés et on est en
espagne c'est à ce moment là c'est pour
ça qu'on a dû changer et la loi mais au
même taux
encore une fois attention la faute n'est
pas aux réseaux sociaux
la faute n'est pas à la population à
c'est lui qui a trouvé au qui a eu la la
vidéo qui a décidé de la publier parce
que science fiction commencé comme ça il
n'y aurait jamais des deux lanceurs
d'alerté on a oublié un moment donné
qu'il ya eu aussi des lanceurs d alerte
ce n'est pas la même qu'à mais ne
mettons pas des barrières à droite et à
gauche pour essayer de vraiment content
sonné ça a une histoire de vie privée et
vie publique
oui ça existe mais en même temps la
peopolisation de la vie politique ce
n'est pas nous les journalistes non plus
qui l'avons créée c'est aussi les
politiques qui sont allés vers elle pour
essayer d'arriver avait osé les aux
électeurs donc ça c'est le risque façon
très faut faire très attention
faut juste se rappeler que cette vidéo
avait été proposé un certain nombre des
médias un média notamment qui arrive qui
a refusé de la voir
d d d d d la date de la présente et
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont allés aussi
sur un site à l'étranger mais attention
cpcc pénale en france donc c'est bien ça
l'est dans l'espagne aussi c'est bien
mais en même temps n'héritons pas la
faute uniquement que sur celui qui l'a
qui l'a publié parce que les hommes
politiques ont aussi une part de
responsabilité dans cette dérive à
laquelle on assiste depuis une dizaine
d'années mais alberti
les hommes politiques ont clairement
pour vous aussi une responsabilité dans
cette affaire
je pense que les hommes politiques ont
une attitude un peu c'est le service
vis-à-vis des médias quand il leur
intéresse les médias ils sont tout
sourire arrête pas de susciter des
interviews et b et d échanges avec les
gars commenter là ils sont intrigués
mina ses parts à des mauvais sondages
vient dé grossesse les évite d'ailleurs
la chose intéressante c'est que j'ai
d'ailleurs selon lui pas des
journalistes en tout cas mais les agents
des organes et donc ça n'est pas du tout
la presse qui a qui a géré ce cas parce
que c'est quelque chose qui est critique
vis-à-vis de la porte-parole actuel qui
a parlé de presse de bas niveau qui
exactement l'expression mais que c'était
pas la presse est d'ailleurs lors d un
milliard justement comme disait mon
confrère a précisé guy vidéo c'était les
réseaux sociaux c'était tout ce qui est
comment dire la latitude de personnes
si l'on veut aussi sur internet mais
sans doute il y à des politiques mais
sans doute il ya une attitude qui pour
différentes mais en même temps je dis
aussi que cette attitude est alimenté
par l'exigence de se mettre un peu un
scène quand ils viennent campagne
électorale quand il y a
un moment d'échangés avec la population
c'est un peu comme si le public voulait
voir un aspect humain désormais de farce
politique mettant en libre quand même
encore une fois ce mot qui revient c'est
l'hypocrisie
parce qu'en fait ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on pourrait parler de la
double vie des françois mitterrand quand
les français ont découvert ça sa double
vie après il acceptait pas non plus de
ne pas savoir qu'il avait une double vie
on a assisté au divorce en direct dé
nicolas sarkozy avec cécilia sarkozy ont
assisté les journalistes savaient mais
gardait voilà aujourd'hui ces citoyens
qui jettent en place et c'est différent
c'est ça la différence c'est ça la
différence ce qui est effectivement
aujourd'hui via le réseau sociaux donc à
nous en tant que journaliste françois
mitterrand les photos et voilà et on
n'essaie rien à l'époque on vit c'est
rien à l'époque parce que la ligne qui
différencie la vie privée la vie
publique était beaucoup plus importante
qu'est ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui et
c'est à nous de faire notre travail et
les voir où est l'information où elle
n'y est pas donc mais c'est vrai que
maintenant aujourd'hui on doit compter
sur les réseaux sociaux
nous on le fait les politiques doivent
doivent les faire mais nenê sur prêts
non pas de voir ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui parce que depuis des
décennies ça se passe selon le voyons
les voyez venir encore on voyait les
divorces en direct on a vu des me
suicide en direct avec la compagne à un
moment donné de monsieur de monsieur
londres tout ça ça se passe maintenant
des ventes tout le monde parce que les
réseaux sociaux sont là cedrico
d'ailleurs avant du gouvernement n'a
ofit et profiter de cette occasion en
tout cas pour suggérer une loi
qui va davantage vers le contrôle
d'internet matteo gisèle berti est ce
que c'est ça la solution
non je suis comme complètement en
désaccord avec cette proposition
comme je suis en désaccord avec la loi
plusieurs aspects de la loi qui misent
qui a limité
on y lira combattre la loi bien sûr il
faut empêcher les états deviennent
anglais de sévir sur internet mais il ya
toujours un risque de limiter la liberté
d'expression
déjà on à l'aller les flics nous c'est
très difficile après de faire notre
travail et donc de faire aussi parfois
les chasseurs d'arette m'alerte si on a
des lois qui continuent à limiter la la
la la la liberté d'expression en
revanche on pouvait par exemple
s'attaquer à un des lois écrit l'ong il
devra plutôt qui protège protège par
exemple les mineurs de façon encore plus
importante parce qu'il faut pas oublier
que toute cette affaire
guilbaud il ya malheureusement une
famille qui équipe qui a été en dira sur
la scène c'est que personne n'avait rien
de l'année et donc je pense que il y a
des marges d'amélioration de changement
d'un justement la protection des mineurs
la peste la protection des personnes
plus faibles qui ne peuvent qu'y qu'ils
pouvaient être exposés sur internet à
des risques qui sont disproportionnés
par rapport à roanne rosé de radeaux
justement aller dans le sens de plus de
protection notamment pour les personnes
les plus fragiles les mineurs parce que
c'est vrai que on parle beaucoup de
benjamin griveaux qui est un homme
j'ai ré majeur vacciner on parle
peut-être moins voilà des victimes des
jeunes qui sont souvent justement en
prise avec ses fameuses revenge port
n'est qu' on souffre beaucoup faire
davantage quand même de protection
niveau oui des protections par rapport
effectivement la population le plus
vulnérable donc les les jeunes notamment
par rapport effectivement assez à ce
phénomène suis tout à fait d'accord avec
lui mais ça ne doit pas non plus aller
audelà a contrôlé la fin de l'anonymat
sur internet au soleil mais on a la clé
political à tokyo ce qu'on ya quelque
chose qu'il n'arrive pas à contrôler ses
affaires une loi pour l'interdire et
donc ça on peut mais on peut pas le
permet tous les journalistes ont laissé
masqué il ya tout un tas des lois qui
délimite blush ou d'investigation des
journalistes on n'a pas le droit de dire
ça on n'a pas le droit de diffuser ça on
n'a pas le droit de donc non il faut
quand même protéger les populations
qu'il faut protéger mais ne généralisons
pas parce que ça n'est pas la société ça
n'aide pas la démocratie ça n'aide que
ceux qui ont coûté sorte quelque chose à
cacher météo sont les albertains le mot
de la fin
oui non effectivement mon confrère toute
occasion est bonne pour essayer
d'introduire une nouvelle loi qui
d'ailleurs pu me aussi un certain type
d'information qui est de toute façon
légitime parce que souvent on peut voir
aussi des amendes représentant tous les
journalistes pour les organes de presse
il faut toujours se rappeler que les
journalistes sont au service de la
communauté
donc il est il donne leur contribution
avec leur travail merci beaucoup en tout
cas tous les deux trois noeuds roses et
dorado matteo gisèle berti merci d'avoir
été avec nous pour ce débat